granadas de aturdimiento y que haces
lacrimógenos para dispersar a una
multitud de manifestantes que se
concentraron en la capital sudanesa a
jartum la revolución continuará y no se
detendrá nuestra demanda básica es vivir
una vida decente en este país y no
renunciaremos a nuestros derechos de
ninguna manera Incluso si se firmaron
acuerdos entre políticos y soldados Esto
no es lo que quiere el pueblo su danés
hace dos semanas líderes militares y
partidos políticos firmaron un acuerdo
en busca de una transición hacia unas
elecciones democráticas con apoyo
internacional un acuerdo que ha sido
calificado de vago y opaco por analistas
y activistas prodemocráticos
hemos dicho cientos de veces que este no
es un compromiso porque un compromiso
debe permitir que ambas partes compartan
las cosas por igual pero lo que está
ocurriendo ahora es una capitulación y
una sumisión a los militares
estas protestas marcaron también el
cuarto aniversario de la Revolución que
provocó la salida de Omar del poder en
abril 2019 en el aniversario de la
revolución de diciembre Espero que el
proceso político haga realidad las
demandas y aspiraciones de los udaces y
sudanesas que salieron a la calle Hace
cuatro años y siguen luchando por un
futuro de paz democracia derechos
humanos e igualdad de los ciudadanos
este lunes los manifestantes marcharon
también para pedir justicia para sus
muertos según líderes prodemocráticos al
menos 122 civiles fallecieron y miles
resultaron heridos desde octubre 2021 a
manos de las fuerzas de seguridad